why don't we go next to Nicole from Utah
Nicole from Utah welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hi David can you hear me yes I can
okay I want your thoughts on just how
many people are entering the Republican
primary race and how they are all saying
the same things about former president
Trump I know and but and they're not
really saying much right I mean is that
sort of part of your point
yes yeah I think that there are a couple
different things going on
it's not a crazy idea to think to
yourself Trump's been arrested once he
may get arrested again he may get
arrested a third time at least and
that's just by this September
he may legitimately struggle to stay in
this race because he will be so tied up
in court and so I want to be there as an
alternative if indeed Trump who has a
commanding lead is unable to run in a
way that makes sense the problem is and
so part of this is if I want to be there
to pick up Trump's supporters I can't be
the one Republican who's running
who is going to do the biggest
criticisms of trump so this is why Tim
Scott and Nikki Haley and whoever else
will talk about it time for a change or
a different generation or whatever but
they won't really go after him the
unfortunate reality for them is that if
you're polling one two three four five
and DeSantis is at 20 something if
indeed Trump has that issue that pushes
him out of the race a lot of that
support will almost certainly go to
DeSantis who is the most viable in the
context of the general election and also
already has the most support and is
using the exact same strategy so far yes
DeSantis has sort of gone after Trump a
little bit but he said he would pardon
him and he's talking more about Joe
Biden than he is about Trump so I think
it's a deliberate strategy from all of
them saying listen let me let me be
around in case Trump collapses but
they're not generating any path to the
nomination for themselves they're sort
of waiting around for one to be handed
to them I don't think it's going to work
I agree with you
all right Nicole from Utah thank you
thanks for having me all right there it
goes Nicole let's go next
to Tai from Iowa Thai from Iowa
hello David can you hear me yes I can
okay so I just wanted to bring this up
because there's just something I kind of
notice
um that uh and I feel like it's it's
usually with either figures that have
passed away like people that have passed
away or it's like uh famous movie or
something like that or a book but
I've I've noticed a bunch of people so
for instance you know how George Orwell
is someone that that people on the right
seem to really really love
they really just talk about things being
orwellian in the sense of 1984 Big
Brother government surveillance
government overreach but I don't know
that they love Orwell many of them don't
even really know what Orwell wrote To be
honest
yeah I know but I just I mean I guess I
just kind of like I just remember seeing
someone on their Twitter bio that was
like a trump page and it said Orwell was
right no I mean I think what we can say
is they like referencing things being
orwellian even if they don't really
understand them that I would agree with
yeah but it's just weird because Orwell
was a socialist yes and he was an
anti-fascist and all this other stuff he
wouldn't here like if if they um think
Biden's a socialist they would think
they would they would just like blush if
they saw someone like Orwell's president
no that's absolutely true and I think
that comes through much more in Animal
Farm which is another Orwell book more
than it does in 1984. the the sort of
socialist ideas I mean listen you have
to understand this right-wing movement
is a movement that has been
anti-intellectual pseudo-intellectual uh
skeptical of or even hostile to deep
thinking and higher education for a long
time now and so the fact that they even
mention Orwell is sort of remarkable but
they know very very little if you say
Hey you know can you kind of compare and
contrast Orwell's Vision in 84 versus
Albus huxley's Vision in Brave New World
and which do you think applies more you
these aren't folks who are able to
engage in on that they've just they
heard orwellian and now they've started
using the term but I don't really think
these are serious people
yeah and then like another one is the
Matrix there's another one so like with
the red pill and all this other stuff
and if there's even a q Anon thing for
follow the White Rabbit and the people
that made the The Matrix are two
transgender sisters yeah yeah no the
identity thing is funny but listen they
don't care that it's just the like like
I said I wouldn't read that much into it
because these truly aren't serious
people we need to get around them to
make progress that's the unfortunate
reality
yeah that makes sense all right Thai
from Iowa thank you for the call
thank you for taking my call David all
right there goes Ty